Time seems to flow.
It has a single direction, moving through
us, pulling the future into the past.
British Astronomer Arthur Eddington, described
this process as 'time’s arrow',
and it is this asymmetrical movement of time
that drives the evolution of our universe,
from its origin in the big bang to its predicted
demise.
We use the second law of thermodynamics to
describe this process.
Entropy, which we might call the level of
chaos or disorder,
has been constantly increasing throughout
the universe since the big bang.
That is to say that the universe is acting
to equalsise the distribution of mass and
energy,
and though this process it has driven the
birth of stars,
the formation of galaxies and the chemical
reactions that gave rise to life.
But it also brings with it death and decay.
But what if this wasn’t the case?
Well the universe as we know it could not
exist.
Without Time’s Arrow, there could be no
stars, no galaxies, and no life.
And at the same time there would be no death,
and no decay.
The movement of mass and energy that sustain
these could not take place.
And therefore entropy and its description
in the second law is interesting
because it helps us distinguish the past from
the future, it provides direction for time’s
arrow.
As the limited amount of energy in the universe
continues to disperse,
it’s predicted that it will eventually reach
equilibrium:
A perfect distribution in which there is no
free energy,
nothing available for stars, no chemical reactions
and no life.
The universe as we know it will become profoundly
quiet.
So make the most of it...
While it lasts.